thank you get to me
[Music]
you have nothing but a war inside you
it's not your fight
[Music]
I need to find these bastards I've got a
cure
so where does that end Frank
what if you're supposed to
these men they decide with the tradition
the same thing that happened to you
happen to me
we could make that right
[Music]
the world needs to see the truth
hey everybody we got some new Punisher
to break down this is just hyping up
episode 1 and all the craziness so if
you don't remember Punisher is dropping
next Friday along with the Justice
League movie I just posted my Justice
League reaction video I'm not allowed to
do reviews for that yet but there's this
sort of spectrum of light tone to really
serious to hardcore stuff happening
between Thor Ragnarok Justice League The
Punisher and then obviously Star Wars in
a couple weeks too so if you like the
way they treated the Thor character but
you're looking for some more hardcore
Marvel this is really the answer to that
you don't get more hardcore than The
Punisher I was actually just making a
Deathstroke video for arrow that I'll
link at the end of this I should
probably do a video comparing the
Punisher to Deathstroke
once the episodes start dropping because
they do have a lot of similarities but I
think the difference with the Punisher
from Deathstroke is is that he's a
little more torn up inside he's still
driven by a lot of the pain that he
feels in losing his family in The
Punisher when he picks up in this series
is still pretty fresh in that he's
trying to take down the men that killed
his family but gets wrapped up in this
larger conspiracy plot with micro
because of all the stuff that Rawlins is
doing and all the evils that he's
perpetrating behind the mask of the CIA
in patriotism there isn't any kind of
crazy embargo or anything like that on
review so my non-spoilery review of the
first couple of episodes will post
sometime early next week but as you
would expect Jon Bernthal just wholly
embodies the character he's an amazing
version of The Punisher so that's
probably the best thing about the serie
like just Jon Bernthal for 13 hours just
being a total badass but I know a lot of
you are also asking about the future of
the Marvel Netflix shows because of this
supposed Disney streaming service so
that's completely unrelated to the plot
and the story of what's going on with
the defenders and all their different
series daredevil season 3 is still
happening in fact the kingpin just went
to set saying that he was going to start
reading the first couple of scripts I'm
sure the first couple of pages of that
is him just beating the [ __ ] out of Matt
for 50 minutes like if you haven't read
daredevil born again that's kind of the
story they're adapting for daredevil
season 3 it is a big kingpin arc so if
you're a big fan of that character he
gets some really cool moments
but I think if there is a Netflix series
that people are looking forward to
that's the one
Daredevils still like the a-list
character inside the defenders even
though Jessica Jones and Luke Cage got a
little more attention because they were
so different from traditional superhero
shows but looking a little bit further
out what might end up happening is is
that Marvel does a couple more seasons
of each of these Netflix shows and then
they just stop their arrangement with
Netflix and produce them for the Disney
streaming service so all the new shows
that Marvel is developing it's
considering for the Disney streaming
service but anything that was already on
Netflix like daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage iron fist Punisher that's
gonna stay on Netflix indefinitely
because Netflix co-owns the series with
Marvel now if Marvel produces something
by itself then it can pull it off so the
only thing that Netflix might end up
losing in the next couple of years is
all the Marvel movies the Disney movies
that means Pixar Star Wars that kind of
stuff so don't worry about them
canceling daredevil or Jessica Jones or
anything like that the series are still
doing really well as long as Netflix
continues to be a good partner and
Marvel enjoys the relationship they'll
keep making it I'm expecting at least
like five seasons of daredevil they've
got like five seasons of most of their
original series I know there's all the
drama with house of cars and the Kevin
Spacey stuff that has nothing to do with
Netflix wanting or not wanting to renew
series there's no real ticking clock on
these Marvel Netflix shows I think the
biggest thing is in them just finding
the right story to tell in finding the
right team to do that story
iron fist is probably the best example
of that so you guys can let me know in
the comments what you want them to do
with the Punisher character but I don't
put any stock in the rumors that they're
trying to bury Punisher because of all
the real world gun violence that's been
happening the last couple of months I
think they just wanted to release it
around this time of the year because
people are getting ready for the
holidays and they tend to binge watch
stuff more so they just want to get the
largest possible audience they're
actually supposed to start shooting iron
fist season too early in December and
like I said last week kingpin was going
to the set of daredevil season 3 to
start doing his script so they're well
into production on daredevil season 3 so
I'm expecting that to drop around this
time next year they've already finished
Jessica Jones season 2
Luke Cage season 2 so those will
probably drop earlier in the year next
year but no official dates for anything
like that when they do announce that
I'll do an update video but there'll be
a whole bunch of stuff happening this
Christmas between the comic book movies
and the comic book TV shows so just make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos and you guys will catch it all
but for those of you asking about agents
of shield and the other Marvel TV stuff
agents of shield actually starts airing
episodes at the beginning of December
because Inhumans just aired their finale
but I'm still doing a movie ticket
giveaway you can use them for whatever
you want all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video congratulations to the winner
from the last video blue werewolf please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my non-spoilery Justice League reaction
and you can click here for all my thor
ragnarok Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight